[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es eine
leckere torte von mir wir machen eine
windbeutel torte allerdings diesmal die
schoko variante ich habe euch letztes
jahr da war ich noch in meiner alten
studenten küche da habe ich euch die
windbeutel torte im sommer steige zeigt
so ein bisschen mit himbeeren teller
creme die ich auch mega das war dann so
eine kuppel torte die verlinke ich euch
gerne und heute gibt irgendwie schoko
variante weil ich habe jetzt überlegt
also die passt auch das ganze jahr über
aber gerade jetzt vor den feiertagen
könnte die zubereiten zu geburtstagen zu
partys also die geht einfach immer zu
alle genau und ich habe jetzt hier schon
mal eine zutaten bereit wir brauchen
natürlich schoko windbeutel falls sie
die nicht findet nimmt einfach die
normalen dann habe ich hier meinen
schoko bizkit boden das video gibt es
extra hier mache ich noch mal einen
kleinen keks boden und zwar habe ich
hier hexe und butter bestreichen werde
ich die böden mit aprikosenmarmelade und
für die creme benötigen wir kalte
schlagsahne maß capone bug und sahne
fest außerdem etwas vanille extrakt
puderzucker für die süße und für den
crash noch ein paar schoko drops jetzt
beginnen wir zuallererst mit der schoko
creme dafür habe ich jetzt hier meine
küchenmaschine ihr könnt ihr auch
notfalls andere gerät benutzen
mit dem stehen die sind funktioniert es
nicht so gut also ich gebe jetzt
zuallererst die mascarpone in die
schüsse und dann die sahne
da könnt ihr auch schon puderzucker
dazugeben und dem backpulver cacau bitte
vorher sieben weil er ebenfalls
klümpchen enthält und wichtig ist bei
dieser creme dass die zutaten ganz
frisch aus dem kühlschrank kommen also
ganz kalt sind
[Musik]
und jetzt mit dem schneebesen aufsatz
erst langsam verrühren und dann immer
schneller werden
[Musik]
dann gebt ihr auch dass vanille extrakt
dazu und das dass seine fest ein riesen
und dann merkt ihr auch nachdem das land
ist mit dazu gekommen ist das ist
relativ schnell fest wird passt bitte
auch und lass das ganze nicht
überschlagen sonst gerinnt die creme das
könnt ihr uns trotzdem noch essen aber
es sieht dann einfach nicht mehr schön
aus also die creme ist wirklich relativ
zügig hergestellt und jetzt gebe ich
etwas weniger als die hälfte der schoko
creme in eine andere schlüsse denn das
brauchen wir nachher für die äußere deko
und zum rest gebe ich die schoko drops
dann haben wir noch richtig leckeren
contin der torte
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich die creme bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
gestellt denn ihr wisst ja seine teams
sollten immer gekühlt werden und in der
zwischenzeit habe ich auch schon mal die
böden vorbereitet das heißt ich habe den
biss geboten zweimal durchgeschnitten
das heißt habe jetzt drei bilden
insgesamt und zusätzlich habe ich ja
diesen leckeren steaks boden dafür
einfach die kekse mit dem blender zum
beispiel fein mahlen und dann
geschmolzener butter dazugeben und
fertig und alles andere zeige ich euch
jetzt hier ganz in ruhe
also ich habe jetzt hier mein typisches
kunstdruck was ich immer habt das
besteht hier unten einmal aus einer
drehbaren tortenplatte das ist wichtig
denn mit ihr damit einfach besser
arbeiten können darüber dann die
tortenplatte auf der ihr die torte
servieren möchte und darüber dann einen
tortenring und in dem fall habe ich den
tortenring mit 15 cm höhe
wenn ihr wisst ja ich möchte dass der
trend zu kleinen trocken also vom
durchmesser her kleine torten geht aber
die dürfen ruhig in die höhe geht und da
habe ich hier den torten mit 15
zentimetern höhe gewählt und jetzt
starten wir aber indem sie zuallererst
den clips boden hier auf dem boden
verteilen und dann schön andrücken dafür
könnt ihr euch zum beispiel ein glas
nehmen
[Musik]
der keks boden steht und das was wir
jetzt ganz einfach machen müssen ist das
ganze was wir jetzt hier noch
vorbereitet haben abwechselnd zu
schichten
das heißt nehmt euch jetzt die
schokocreme mit den schoko drops
verteilt die gibt da ordentlich
windbeutel rein und dann ganz einfach
die schoko basket bonn und ich
persönlich mag das total gerne wenn die
schoko bis gebilden jetzt noch mit
aprikosenmarmelade gestrichen werden
falls ihr das nicht mögt dann lass es
einfach weg aber vertraut mir dieses
fruchtige gibt der ganzen heute noch mal
so ein bisschen leichtigkeit
[Musik]
so die torte ist jetzt komplett fertig
gestapelt und ich werde jetzt die
oberfläche ist somit ein bisschen creme
bestreichen
damit es eben nicht austrocknet und dann
lasse ich das nur für 20 minuten im
kühlschrank gehabt der saane fest drin
das heißt es ist eigentlich schon alles
fest aber zur sicherheit noch mal 20
minuten in die kühlung und dann machen
wir auch schon die weko
[Musik]
nach der kurzen zeit eine torte mit der
übrig gebliebenen credit ja anfangs zur
seite gelegt habe einmal rundherum
glaubt einstreichen nicht immer dafür am
liebsten mal detail karte und dann muss
sie noch mal gekühlt werden einfach aus
folgendem grund weil jetzt der druck
kommt und für den dhb muss eben die
torte zumindest aus nur richtig schön
fest werden und dafür gebe ich sie für
eine stunde in den kühlschrank falls ihr
das ihm zeit technisch schon ein
bisschen ein plan dann macht das alles
sehr gerne über nacht und noch die deko
am nächsten tag nicht machte sie über
nacht sondern macht es am vortag könnte
sie über nacht und dann könnt ihr die
deko machen aber bei mir war sie jetzt
finde stunden im kühlschrank und jetzt
geht es weiter für den trip habe ich
hier ganz einfach voll mich völlig
kuvertüre und butter und ich mache das
immer gerne so dass ich es jetzt ganz
easy in die mikrowelle gebe verrühren
und dann zeige ich euch wie ich die
dritte
[Musik]
und mit dem trip das funktioniert
eigentlich wie von alleine wenn ihr vor
allem die drehbare tortenplatte und
runter hat könnte immerhin zentimeter
weiter drehen und dann seid ihr
eigentlich schnell durch jetzt habe ich
an die oberfläche auch ein bisschen von
dem trip gegeben das heißt alles ist
voller und sobald es trocknet nehme ich
mir meine restliche creme die habe ich
hier in meinen spritzbeutel gefüllt
vorne nur offene stelle dran ich
verlinke ich euch auch in die infobox
und dann spritzt sich damit einfach du
noch ein paar häuschen und dann kommen
dann noch windbeutel drauf habe ich mir
überlegt wo bei der deko bin ich immer
ein bisschen spontan gegen ende aber
auch der abschluss muss dekoriert werden
und dafür habe ich hier mandl krokant
und das haftet auch ganz einfach auf der
schoko creme also einfach ganz leicht
andrücken
[Musik]
und fertig ist die schoko windbeutel
torte sieht die nicht einfach nur schick
aus also schon fast so eine
deluxe-edition wenn die auf dem
geburtstagstisch stellt oder auch den
festakt ish oder oder oder
die leute werden augen machen das
verspreche ich euch und ich finde das
aussehen ist wichtig sondern die inneren
werte sehen wir auch ja und er ist
einfach lecker da ist schokolade ich
nicht so mächtig das verspreche ich euch
die ist wirklich nicht zu mächtig mit
der aprikosenmarmelade habt ihr noch so
perfekten ausgleich und immer immer noch
so ein quatsch auch so ein schoko drogba
ist oder ob ein windbeutel dann freut
man sich einfach und das ist jetzt sehr
hohe tonnen das heißt entweder schneidet
ihr schmales stück könnte er dann sogar
auf den teller link oder was ich mal
gerne mache ich noch mal ein stück teile
in der mitte durch und dann bekommt ihr
da auch ich würde sagen 24 stück heraus
also 24 ganz normal große stücke so und
jetzt wünsche ich euch natürlich ganz
viel freude beim nachbacken hier in der
video beschreibung schreibe ich euch
immer ganz genauen mengenangaben rhein
alles was ich benutzt haben die meisten
sagen findet ihr im shop und
mittlerweile auch die küchenmaschine
nach der so viele fragen schaut einfach
in die infobox und dann ganz ganz ganz
viel freude beim nachbacken und ich
möchte euro fotos sehen postet sie auf
instagram und facebook und takt milch
ich schreibe euch meinen kanal auch hier
rein in die infobox dann könnt ihr mir
dort folgen wenn dies nicht schon längst
macht und ich kann einfach nicht mehr
viel drum herum entlasse euch jetzt und
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
hier auf meinem kanal zu haben so gar
nichts gesagt
[Musik]